there she was all below tribal with her
braids and feathers debuting her song
misery while Blake watched with pride
but what you saw was pre-taped an hour
before the show here's what you didn't
see behind-the-scenes even though she
aims like didn't share any screen time
on air they were not shy at all about
being seen as a couple when the cameras
weren't rolling in between each take
they would get up and talk to each other
at one point Blake even whispered
something in Gwen's ear really made it
seem like he was encouraging her where
are you going it was a family affair for
the couple
when snap chatted throughout the show
sharing shots for boys and even Blake's
got Betty it really is like a family
dynamic on the voice all the coaches are
so close and even Christina Aguilera was
totally rocking out to Gwen's
performance and we saw Blake give Gwen a
standing ovation she didn't really seem
to look at him much during her
performance except once to flash him a
little smile but what happened right
after she left the stage she high-fived
Adam as she was walking off the stage
and Blake wasted absolutely no time
coming over to meet her they walked out
of the building together where one of
Gwen's assistants handed her son Apollo
to her Blake then didn't come back for
about another 20 minutes until the live
show started like appears to be so good
with when three boys but he told us it's
way too early to start talking about
kids of their own
you